like you said like
there's there's like especially with
these
there's you know a lot of these kids in
these younger generations like you look
like what's going on in jacksonville
with the hip-hop [ __ ] right now it's
so insane wow yo kev i just say as a
black man this [ __ ] dishes me
to see like like when i was growing up
listening to music we all we grew up on
the same music yeah
i never heard nobody like like when it
was when when artists would diss each
other they might have had a problem
backstage or something but it was more
centered around you can't it was more
centered around the hip hop
the bars it's just like and sometimes
there'll be some personal [ __ ] involved
but it was never like but the thing
about it is what i'd be finding out with
a lot of these stories is like
all right these kids be getting into a
lot of this [ __ ] when like
when i was 14 i got into a lot of stupid
[ __ ] but like
these kids it'd be like y'all play
basketball together
or you y'all used to sleep at each
other's house or his his aunt is your
mom best friend and
y'all and then y'all now y'all just
super murderers like you know what i
mean and
the the thing about it is like nobody
don't talk about like the post trauma
with these kids go through
no everybody sit here act like
they just this murder and killer they're
not talking about like the piece of
their self they lose when they might
have did some [ __ ] like that
you know what i mean yeah man the waking
up the night i like i think about like
the young and ace kid who put out the
record
yeah the whole world bro
it's so crazy but i've met him and
interviewed him and he seems like a nice
genuinely like sweet kid and then he
puts out
and then the other kid puts out a record
on the the the graveyard of his like
it's like it's crazy like where the hell
i don't know bro but you know what's
crazy
most the artists that i meet because
this is the thing i've been in this [ __ ]
bro
i was i was really brought up in this
[ __ ] around state property
right i'm saying so it's like which
we'll get to yeah but i'll just say this
before we get to that
beanie siegel might be the toughest
person i've ever met in my life i mean
when he
when he was at that time but who he was
to everybody
when we came out the house because i
lived with beanie siegel when he was on
house arrest who he was
when we came out the house was a
different person than where i knew him
how i knew him how his mother knew him
his kids knew him so i understand that
like
a lot in hip-hop we got this [ __ ]
this wall built up that we don't want to
like break down and
we ain't got no feelings we ain't got no
remorse we ain't got none of that and
that [ __ ] ain't the case and i feel like
a lot of that [ __ ]
as me being a black man is at the
detriment of the black man
you know what i mean because it's like i
would hate to see young ace or the
whoever the other kid he's beefing with
lugiano kid yeah
yeah uh fuliana because fuji was like
that yeah you're right yeah so
i i'm confusing my young man but i would
hate to see
one of them go down for some crazy [ __ ]
because at the end is bro you hurting
your moms
like you're in an opportunity you got an
opportunity where you can build some
[ __ ] music has changed
so many people on this planet's lives
where it's like you got the opportunity
to like really
change your life for generations i don't
know if they care about that enough
because it's hard to tell a young
brother
to see that for i didn't see that far
when i was that young but i'll just be
like
let's move your mic in the middle of you
oh okay boom there we go all right okay
better but like i'm just like yo bro
y'all gotta start noticing that y'all
have value when these record labels sign
you
and give you all that money which ain't
no money to them all that's cute
right but you have value that's the only
reason why they [ __ ] with you because
you have value
now that value that they see in you you
need to take that and build on that and
filter that into your family
because because bro nothing's realer
than putting your loved ones in a box
right nothing's really than that [ __ ]
and if you leaning towards that type of
[ __ ] you ain't
for nothing but destruction